look fair warning my opening jokes gonna
be considered a spoiler okay here we go
you know what you need to do when you
want to deal with the undead be calling
the ladies it was actually just a fun
coincidence that I was already wearing
this shirt when I watch this thing hey
everybody its Game of Thrones third
episode of the last season this puts us
at the halfway mark account having
finished this and mmhmm yeah that was
the thing so this is the big battle that
was promised Wow
I was gonna say by the previous episode
I would actually say that's been
promised by most of the show for up to
this point and and again I already gave
you spoiler warning the night king is
dead a bunch of care of huh here's the
thing I was gonna say a bunch of named
characters most of whom like I know on
site but whose names I actually cannot
readily remember have died Theon's dead
I know his name but we got a whole bunch
of deaths whole bunch of mayhem I have
slightly mixed feelings about the
episode basically HBO did not throw as
much money at this as they should have
for the scale of it I know that sounds
weird
for how much money HBO spends on this
show but what I mean by that is it's
really well done in terms of pacing size
scope progress having you know the right
beats as it goes along to slow it down
without making it seem like everything's
gonna be okay that is all done
incredibly well however there were
significant chunks of the actual action
where I had a really hard time figuring
out what the hell was going on because
of a how friggin dark it was which yes
was moody and creepy and a few shots and
a few instances and sometimes visually
worked out well but other times I'm like
okay stop cuttin slow down and
like the friggin scene and then in
addition there's so much just crap in
the frame often times that a lot of the
more effects-heavy moments they just
look like garbage and I'm like the
dragon on dragon fights were by far the
least interesting thing in this episode
because I couldn't tell what the heck
was going on so like for comparison you
can go all the way back to the Battle of
Blackwater and the there's really only
one really noticeable effect shot in
that and that is the the wildfire I
think that's what they call it the green
flame stop burning the fleet that is a
big shot it's a clear shot it's a good
shot but it's because it's basically the
only one they had to do that's not to
say that that episode was cheap it
wasn't but everything else that they had
to spend money on was practical they
just had to they had to have the extras
they had to have the armor they had you
know that sort of thing which if you've
got it as long as you don't shoot it
like an amateur it's going to look good
whereas heavy effects yeah if you don't
have the time or the money to do them
right you know it's not it's not enough
just to have them there for size and
scope if you've got enough physical
bodies in place you can make it look big
but when it comes to these extra things
not so much so it I feel in I don't
think I mentioned this in my previous
episode that I went into this nervous
that I was going to not be able to see a
good chunk of what was going on and
while it wasn't as bad as I was afraid
it was going to be and I could at least
for the most part follow the flow of the
battle if not all the specific
individual action beats that were going
on
ie it could have been better
was it as bad as I thought or at least
it was afraid it was going to be so yeah
moving on from that I think my favorite
moment in this was actually the quiet
moment between Tyrion and Sansa when
they're down there in tears like I
should go up I might spot something
nobody else does and Sansa just drags
him down to earth like
we're down here because we can't help
and the best thing that we can do is
stay out of the way and just face the
truth of our situation and him
appreciating her for doing that that's a
great little moment and like I said a
moment like that doesn't actually make
you go oh I feel like everything's gonna
be okay it's just a pause it's a moment
to take a breath there are a few of
those and like it happens when they
light the trenches that holds the army
of the Dead back for a little bit so we
can take a breather because you can't
just have her at hammer on relentlessly
because that's just numbing if you dial
it up to 11 but just leave it there then
it's the same as having it just as at
one it's the repetition it doesn't
matter what the level is if it just
stays in one place it numbs you so
you've got to take the dips you've gotta
you've got to AB and flow of the thing
and like I said this thing's really well
paced quite well done definitely in that
regard I am left wondering about a few
people like okay they singled out this
person died and this person dying and
they were and like I saw a ghost
in the charge that the Dothraki did I
didn't see him come back did we loose
another direwolf because I feel like
more attention should have been paid if
that happened but so characters who did
die there's eyepatch guy with the
flaming sword he's dead
Oh little lady more Hmong that one hurt
I think that won't probably hurt the
most for me but out like a boss taking
down a giant yep she's she is up there
in tough-as-nails lady heaven just
trading badass stories with ol IANA
Tyrell I can live with that so her going
down going down fighting like that okay
that was
that still gotta hurt to see her go
Melisandre Ella was a little weird for
me because like the nature of the death
like it worked and it was fitting I feel
like it was a weird note to actually end
the episode on though I'm not entirely
sure why they did that but I mean it in
a have itself it worked
totally fine um there's probably another
guy whose name I can't remember like
John's other main like night Night Watch
bro who isn't Sam forget his name like I
have a way better memory for faces than
I do for names which is actually a big
part of why I opted to not try and read
the books but to watch the show because
I can recognize a face and go I know
that face and I know from here here here
it's that guy but I there's a decent
chance I still will not remember the
name so when you try the idea of trying
to read the book were all I have is a
name and I don't have a face to put it
to yeah that's that's mmm yeah
that's intimidating but so yeah he went
down and I I gotta I gotta take my hat
off for this one
Liz cuz she not only called it that the
night king was gonna bite it in this
episode but also that Aria was gonna be
the one to do it she did also predict
that Aria would die in the process of
doing it which doesn't appear to have
happened but that's two out of three on
like the big climactic moment so props
to my partner she nailed that
and that also felt good and like it's
it's something so simple there were a
couple of really simple like twists not
like my baby who this changes everything
twists but like oh dang moments and that
was one the other one being like the
bodies in the crypt cuz the thing was
like after it started happening part of
me went shouldn't somebody have thought
of that but at the same time I was going
well I did think of that and so like oh
dang
so like that's the kind of twisted
complication I think is really good
because it's the shows playing fair it
didn't like pulled this out of its butt
it just and unless you completely
overanalyze which some of us do and it's
not a criticism of you if you do odds
are you didn't stop and think oh they're
in the crypt they're surrounded by dead
people that the night king can raise
that idea because I didn't think that um
so I like that and then you know Aria
you know she goes for him he stops her
and and like when I II got excited and
then she dropped her dagger I'm like oh
no
but then she caught it with the other
hand came in underneath am i ah yes so
that was that was nicely satisfying
there was something that I predicted
that never happened and I feel like it
was a missed opportunity I feel like it
would have been a really phenomenal
creepy unsettling image I'm surprised we
never got an undead Hodor well I I feel
like in general we didn't really get
much in the way of undead characters
we'd seen before I mean granted it could
feasibly be a little bit tricky to do
things as there aren't like you're
either one of the white walkers or
you're just one of the undead masses
like there's no there's no sergeants on
the field it's just throwing bodies at
at the enemy until they get overwhelmed
so I don't know maybe it would have been
too cheesy but I feel like that I feel
like somebody we should have seen
somebody and for me Hodor was the
obvious one to go with I suppose the
giant we could count and I guess the
dragon if you wanted to but like though
those were those are slightly inhuman
characters though so I feel like there
should have been someone like oh I
remember that guy but they never did so
I and it was funny once Liz made the
prediction to me that she thought the 19
was gonna die this episode I remember
thinking going yeah you're probably
right because there's only six episodes
this
even if they don't succeed in killing
him this episode they're gonna have to
try again presumably in the actual last
episode but that comes so quickly on the
heels of the previous failed attempt
that it feels repetitive and redundant
it makes way more sense for them to kill
him here and then we deal with Cersei
for the last half of the last season
which looks like that's gonna be what
they do um which is going is both smart
but also going to be tricky
it is smart because the thing about the
night king is there's no emotional
investment in him as a villain he's
scary or at least his army is certainly
scary and in the whole like it's like a
flood of dead people but you know
there's no real emotional investment in
him he's not a character he's a force of
nature so you can't have the emotional
payoff and catharsis and defeating him
you can with Searcy I think they're
gonna have a hard time coming anywhere
close to the spectacle in terms of
taking on Searcy I would kind of presume
that at this point this was most of
their budget so that they're probably
not gonna try for that anyways but who
knows so I mean we'll see how it pays
off but certainly in terms of paying off
the emotional investment which
ultimately does matter more than the
spectacle I mean at the end of the day
at least I think it does this this was
the right call and so yeah overall I
liked it I've gotten it picks it was too
dark some of the effects
yo they did they you know what it
reminded me of it reminded me of that
first like that jailbreaks scene in the
crimes of Grindelwald a fantastic piece
too because I hated that scene because
it like it took place on a flying
carriage at night in a storm in the rain
I'm like I can't tell what's going on
and I have to wonder did you think this
was Moody or did you add all this crap
on here to hide the fact that the
effects don't look good and I have to
wonder a little bit of the same thing
was going on here but aside from that
overall plotting everything nicely done
Game of Thrones whoo that was a biggie
what are your thoughts on this episode
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it what's
tough to do buttons links patreon merch
blah blah blah blah blah click on the
stuff down in the description it'll take
you places and give you the opportunity
to do things but you also don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]